sally a little boy died earlier this
week in a shooting police call
preventable
this tragic situation has sparked a new
conversation regarding gun safety
8 news 9 reporter madison kimbrough went
to a local gun range today
she joins us live in the newsroom with
some important safety tips madison
yeah it's a story we hear way too often
of people mishandling their firearms
and now with the pandemic more and more
people are buying guns without proper
knowledge
of how to handle them
gun safety has always been a huge topic
of discussion
and after this past wednesday's incident
of a mother accidentally killing her
three-year-old son
the need for education when handling and
owning a firearm
is vital in the state of nevada there
are no licenses
mandatory waiting periods or
registrations to purchase firearms
but federal law requires licensed
firearm dealers to run a background
check
on prospective purchasers places like
the range 702 make it their mission to
educate everyone that walks in their
door
on the importance of knowing how to
handle a gun safety classes
and education here for us is exactly and
just as important
as selling a firearm obviously we
believe it's really important to
be able to protect yourself equally it's
just as important to be able to know how
to use that firearm that you're
purchasing
at the range 702 training a potential
buyer is just as important as making a
sale
these are weapons we're dealing with and
even though training isn't required by
law
educating the public is something the
gun store is very passionate about
and prides itself in what we noticed is
there was just a lack of education so we
actually decided to fill that gap
and create one-on-one training classes
where people who
now have the need to have a firearm arm
in their home and
want to protect their family can
actually protect their family because
they know how to use the firearm part of
training also includes the ideal spot
for your weapon when keeping it in the
house
we'll go over where and how to store
your firearm oddly enough it's very
specific
depending on your home depending on your
firearm and depending on who you have in
your home
as for the three-year-old boy and his
mom his mother 25-year-old jasmine
vargas
claims she had no idea there was a round
in the chamber
and while she was legally in possession
of the newly acquired firearm
she told police she had no experience
loading the weapon
and that her boyfriend had loaded it for
her
now the investigation is still ongoing
but this is now a case for metro's abuse
and neglect division
and vargas was booked on a charge of
child abuse with substantial bodily harm
including death reporting live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough
8 news now